Facebook software can track you even
after you quit Facebook it's still
tracking you
which is why Facebook now wants to know
what the hell you're doing with that
[ __ ] Pinterest
[Applause]
what she got that I own got lots of
different curtains and throw pillows
we've had this conversation here's a
weird story in Tennessee a man sued
Pizza Hut after he allegedly broke a
denture biting into quote an excessively
hard crouton yeah which begs the
question who goes to Pizza Hut and
orders the salad
[Applause]
the tell of the shower right now with
lots of greens that guy doesn't exist I
know that crouton was probably in a
glass box they had to break like because
they nobody ever orders it give him the
crouton Nick crouton someone heard the
salad well there's more news about
Indiana's religious freedom law that
many are saying is anti-gay more news
about it Indiana lawmakers claim they're
going to tweak the new law to prove it's
not discriminatory to gays they say
they're going to tweak it so it's not
discriminatory to gays yeah for example
they're lifting the ban on live tweeting
the Tonys that's going to go away that
was a lot Harley that's a walk Wow
people who could get arrested I'm not
making this next one up this is true and
I have actually they've all been real
now you tell them now I tell them be
funny if I came out with fake premise
yeah yeah yeah we all heard about that
camel
a camel that went to Mars uh audience
what I guess he knows what he's doing
yesterday Burger King this is true
Burger King unveiled its new whopper
scented Cologne he came out with a
whopper scented Cologne so ladies if he
smells like a whopper he's either
wearing the Cologne or he just ate one
even one he's a keeper that guy walked
through the why that's how I do is
that's why people go to Burger King for
the smell it's their new slogan in New
York City a woman gave birth in the back
of an uber yeah
even more impressive the uber app told
her the baby will be here in five
minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a girl hanging through the cervix
sorry to give you an anatomy lesson
people I had him I had him right where
they want and then you took us to the
certain need-to-know beardo Matthew
McConaughey's in the news Matthew
McConaughey is being paid a hundred and
thirty-five thousand dollars to make a
commencement speech yeah yeah folks that
works out to $4,000 per all right
[Applause]
this is briefcase and walked out the
door rolling stones are in the news the
Rolling Stones have announced a 15 city
tour of North America 15 said oh yeah
Mick Jagger said it's the biggest tour
they've done on a single continent since
these stones toured Pangaea
that's funny cuz Pangaea was back when
all the continents were one easily two
billion years ago that makes the stones
over two billion years old and that
makes that joke
[Applause]
thank you oh look I just got an award
for that joke
you